mirror mirror on the wall who's the
baddest villain parent of them all we've
got some clues about the missing parents
of the villain kids in the Disney
descendants movies watch until the end
to find out which of the villain kids
might actually be siblings say I'm just
just trying to teach you the thing that
really counts how to be me
the villains on the Isle of the Lost
have certainly been busy since their
banishment to that crowded chunk of land
with no magic in descendants they
establish that the villain kids mal Evie
Jay and Carlos are the children of
Maleficent the Evil Queen Jafar and
Cruella De Vil respectively we know that
they didn't exactly have a flair for a
loving parenting in fact they're
downright mean and selfish to their kids
now grows up being praised for things
like backstabbing her best friends Evie
thinks she must flirt with and
manipulate men to get what she wants Jay
is a thief and Carlos has an irrational
phobia of dogs not exactly the best
marks of good parenting in the first
movie the villain parents tried to
manipulate the villain kids into
stealing fairy godmothers wand so they
could destroy the barrier around the
Isle
thankfully for auradon mal and her
friends chose to be good
Maleficent didn't take the news very
well she took advantage of a breach in
the barrier and escaped to Oregon where
she terrified everyone when she turned
into a dragon
[Music]
unfortunately for Maleficent she was
magically transformed into a tiny lizard
in fact all four of the transferred
villain kids stood up to their parents
and decided to stay in Oregon all the
villain kids seemed to be doing well
without their parents in fact we haven't
seen much of the villain parents since
the first movie but fans still have one
major question about the villains on the
Isle why are they all single parents
we've got some theories about the
whereabouts of these missing parents
Mal's dad everyone is pretty sure that
Hades is mouse dad but we won't know for
sure until descendants 3 comes out in
the novel the Isle of the Lost Mouse
father is mentioned a few times
one thing Maleficent says about mouths
dad is that he's a pathetic little human
that doesn't really match up with the
theory that mouths dad is Hades Hades
isn't human he's the Lord of the
underworld but was he once human before
whatever happened it's clear that it
didn't work out between mouths dad and
Maleficent so that means mouths only
real role model was an angry bitter
magic list sorceress with a singular
mission of revenge it's a wonder mal
turned out decent at all so what
happened to split up Mouse parents maybe
there's only room for one narcissistic
selfish cruel parent in the family can
you imagine an argument between Hades
and Maleficent if they had access to
their magic they would have made their
Castle explode in a fiery display of
blue and purple flames one thing is
certain all the fans are excited to see
mouths reunion with her long-lost father
but if it is Hades will he be on mouth
side or is he the one draining her magic
from the latest Hades trailer that
Disney released it's clear that Hades
has a score to settle
he's bitter that he's been exiled to
live out his days
with no magic no freedom he wants to
make the king and queen of auradon pay
for what they've done since the king and
queen are the parents of mouths
boyfriend that would put him at odds
with mal and we know from the mystery
trailer that mal is trying to get her
hands on Hades ember so this may not be
the happy father-daughter reunion we've
all been waiting for
Evie's dad we know that grim Hildy aka
the Evil Queen is the most beautiful and
cruel Queen on the Isle so who could
Evie's dad possibly be one fan believes
it could be Gaston from Beauty and the
Beast when you think about it that makes
a lot of sense he's vain like the Evil
Queen he wanted only the best most
beautiful woman in the land but then
Belle chose the Beast now technically
Gaston fell off the castle at the end of
Beauty and the Beast but did he really
meet his demise according to the actor
who voiced the character the answer is
no in an interview he shared that he is
100% certain that Gaston just had a bad
fall
he thinks Gaston probably just got a
nasty bump and may have forgotten
himself for a while
perhaps he has a bit of villain amnesia
but Richard White is convinced we'll see
him again but we're not totally
convinced after all the animators did
draw skulls in the pupils of his eyes
which is a pretty big indicator that he
didn't survive the fall that would make
it impossible for him to be Edie's dad
and also that would make easy and Gil
half brother and sister speaking of half
sisters there's another fan theory that
would turn Edie's besties into her half
sister this fan theory points to Hades
as Edie's potential father if he's also
mouths dad that would make mal and Evie
half sisters if Hades dated both
Maleficent and the Evil Queen we doubt
he would live to tell the tale but maybe
he was protected from their vengeance by
being locked up another more feasible
theory is that Evie's father is the
Huntsman you know the guy who ran Snow
White out into the woods in the animated
film however he was supposed to bring
the Queen Snow White's heart in a box
and he didn't do it we can't imagine the
Evil Queen letting him live that one
down Jays mom Jafar is among the other
evil single parents on the Isle whose
past is a bit of a mystery besides
jasmine he never had a love interest
he seemed only interested in power and
control on the Isle he's obsessed with
finding the lamp with the genie inside
so he can make his wishes come true but
who could Jays mom actually be one fan
had quite an interesting theory about
this when you look at Jay you can see
that he's clever charismatic nimble
acrobatic and a master thief mmm that
sounds like another character from a
classic Disney movie Aladdin and Jay are
so much alike that it's spooky
in fact Jay bears a closer resemblance
too Aladdin than he does to Jafar
additionally Jafar talks about jasmine
on several occasions in The Descendants
movie Disney fans are like expert
detectives many of them came to the
conclusion that Jame might actually be
the son of aladdin and Jasmine but that
Jafar cast some sort of spell on them
and stole Jay for himself that way he
could have someone to do his bidding
while he is stuck on the aisle
so maybe jasmine and Aladdin are
completely oblivious to the fact that
they may have a son and that he's been
kidnapped and that he was stuck living
out his days on the Isle of the lost
until Ben invited him in the rest of the
vks to auradon so will we be seeing more
than one parent reunion in d3
we'll have to just wait and see Carlos
so Carlos his mom Cruella De Vil is
downright frightening she's not only
ruthless against people who get in her
way but she's also not exactly a friend
to the canine world either chibios all
living beings as there to serve her
needs including her own son she made him
sleep in her closet to protect her furs
she instilled a crippling irrational
fear of dogs in him from an early age
she makes him scrape the bunions off of
her feet burros she seems like the worst
mother in the bunch so who would want to
marry and have a kid with this monstrous
woman many fans have speculated that she
could have hooked up with one of her
henchmen Jasper or Horace another fan
has suggested King candy from wreck-it
Ralph as the bad guy who stole Cruella's
heart but Carlos may never find out the
truth about who his father really is who
L it doesn't seem like the kind of
mother who would sit her son down for a
heart-to-heart talk since it must get
lonely on the Isle there's a chance that
Jafar and Cruella got together at some
point
that would make Carlos and Jay
half-brothers that would explain their
playful chemistry there constantly play
fighting and wrestling
around they definitely have that
brotherly energy between them the
regardless of who Carlos's dad could be
it's clear that Cruella couldn't hold
down a steady relationship that's
because she views others as only there
to serve her not to mention she keeps
talking to that stuffed dog on her
shoulder and that is just weird
Celia we don't know much about Celia and
her dad dr. facili yet in an interview
at the Disney fan fest Judah Murray
shared that Celia is a daddy's girl she
also mentioned that she's all about the
cash just like her father so it seems
like they're pretty close but who is see
Leah's mother we would venture to say
that Celia came to dr. facili a as part
of a deal he made with an unsuspecting
victim of his voodoo magic he doesn't
exactly deal fairly with people so what
if he sort of Rumplestiltskin to his way
into having a daughter of his own that
would make it hard to pin down her real
parents they could be anybody who got
tricked by the great voodoo doctor the
only ones who know for sure are his
friends on the other side
uma uma clearly takes after her mother
Ursula she's got the same sass the same
bad temper and the same octopus morphing
abilities it's gotta be hard to make
room for anyone else among all those
tentacles Ursula wanted to be the queen
of the Seas she tried to overthrow King
Triton and wound up with a ship in the
gut instead she also went after Prince
Erik as Vanessa when she stole Ariel's
voice this sea witch will stop at
nothing to snag a royal man and take all
of his power so what if Prince Erik was
tricked into falling for Ursula sometime
after the Little Mermaid
that would make Prince Erik Lumas dad
but that doesn't quite seem to fit with
Houmas personality and abilities we
think it could be king training we're
not sure how but maybe Huma is the love
child of King Triton and Ursula that
would make Ariel and all of her sisters
related to amass either King Triton
doesn't know that uma is his daughter or
he's trying to distance himself from the
most terrifying sea witch in the ocean
another possibility for umas father is
the evil pirate who tried to destroy
Peter Pan that's right we're talking
about Captain Hook
this would make emma and harry half
sister and brother that would explain
their chemistry and inseparable bonds
many fans have been shipping these two
pretty hard but what if they turned out
to be related
that would be totally gross after
examining all of the villain parents on
the aisle one thing seems quite apparent
none of them seem capable of sustaining
a loving relationship they're all
selfish evil greedy vengeful lying
thieving power-hungry people who
shouldn't be anyone's parents at the end
of the day that's why the V Ches only
have one parent each they couldn't get
along with anyone else for long enough
to create a loving family and the
parents who stuck around only did so
because they wanted to use their kids to
do their evil bidding it's no wonder mal
and the gang wanted to flee to ordered
on they had to escape a terrible
upbringing with parents who didn't love
them the only thought of themselves why
do you think the villain kids only have
one parent do you agree with our
theories about who their parents could
be and do you think we'll see any of the
other potential parents in descendants 3
sound off in the comments below thanks
for watching the themes be sure to
subscribe to our channel for the latest
descendants news and don't forget to
give this video a big thumbs up see you
later
[Music]